okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things YouTube channel
um today we are gonna go through a day
in my life what it is like going on
podcasts and we are traveling so before
we start make sure you like the video
let's get started
okay I see a lot of Haram here okay
they're passing out like pictures and
stuff okay what is called Sin City yeah
you know so why would I move somewhere
like you want to have a family whatever
but when you're not on this trip it's
normal it's normal it's completely
normal are there conservatives here I
really like considers of course I don't
know
a conservative State maybe there's a gun
in the bag I was just holding
I do even
if that I can recruit feminists plus so
as long as there's not enough right well
you're close to La so there's plenty
I'll see you women say well how do you
know you know I'll be fine I don't need
a medicine because everybody that was 25
when I was 25 who said that they're my
age now and they're ending up on Tick
Tock single and still can't find a man I
said oh you'll find one one day Jesus is
close don't worry about it
no that's the they do they marry Jesus
they go to no it's weird when you listen
to them I swear I swear to God this is
like like they stop having sex with
everyone else so they it's like they're
married to Jesus oh right and like then
it's so weird the way they talk about
God it like sounds like how you would
talk about a husband like men don't talk
about God that way it's a very weird
phenomenon yeah in the church but I hear
I don't know what it is I hear what
you're saying though when you look at
Vegas but here's the whole thing you
gotta remember everybody outside of
Vegas only sees Vegas from one light
yeah the film industry and they say oh
that's Vegas yeah that is in Vegas
no the church girls are very crazy like
the church gets on me because I I always
talk about their crazy women yeah but
I'm like how are the guys going to
church in here and finding worse women
than the general I mean you want your
daughter's daughter to be a horse under
the Catholic School right
guys
go find the Catholic group right
just do come at me a lot you get the
whales the churches and who else the
Chris no the Christians wait what are
the whales the whales are
okay they just grind my gears the
Christian simps also irritate me they
just and this is the funny thing because
everyone like I guess how I dress or
talk they're like oh she's like a
die-hard Bible whatever and I'm like
well but the the Simpson the church just
irritate me because they sell this bill
of dreams to women you can do whatever
you want and become a born-again virgin
I'm like who's selling this like like
Vegas is cool I like it
did the podcast had a lot of fun tonight
we're going to dinner we'll see how it
goes let me know what should I do in
Vegas next time I'm here I'm new to this
this life you know
the reason why to interpret the energy
astrology like for instance
Warren you're basically imprinted with
energy and if you understand how to
basically read the numbers it'll help
you share a lot when it comes to
understanding what people are going to
be doing personality wise what they're
gonna look like and then again
environment plays a role in your life
because it's kind of like going with the
energy
um you go with the with the tide
it's a lot easier when you go with the
tide when you go against the tide things
get difficult and everyone has points in
their life where bad things happen if
that's the conversation you want to
think I think we live in the virtual
reality called The Matrix uh you know
not the way these other people describe
the Matrix as the government
we all know the Rothschilds are running
the show that The Matrix is the energy
virtual reality system we live in and
that is the reason why numerology and
astrology work because this is a false
realm there's no other reason for this
informational work or you know and once
you understand this is a false Realm
[Music]
no more sense
today is day two of podcasting so we're
doing another podcast
Studio no one's here I must have got the
time wrong or something I don't know
I know I've had a lot of smoke for
whales lately okay I just think it's so
big like I'm gonna run later I'm gonna
do some workouts okay I'm gonna try all
these desserts
look it and we're gonna raid him me and
blessing
that one's okay it's a little too rich
for me I'm gonna give that three
which one is that that's this one 3.5
that's pretty good I thought that was
the best one so far
that's the one I'm sorry I'm trying to
not be a whale whale me I have no
obligation
I'll explain to you the red pill and
Andrew Tate so a lot of people don't
really understand the Dynamics of like
things behind the scenes and I see a lot
of things you guys don't
but let's just say the red pill was like
a bunch of guys 20 years ago that came
together and basically said we have all
these issues with women are these
problems and they basically just
compared notes okay so last thing it
would be like if you said my girlfriend
said this to me today she said I need
space like what does that mean because
you know I know now this is like common
knowledge I need space means I'm Just
Not That Into You that sort of thing but
back then it's like the guys are like
well
what is what does that mean right or
they a girl would break up with them for
a day cheat and then get back together
with them I was like anyways I don't
know because I'm not I I didn't study a
girlfriend or anything you know but so
they basically came together and shared
notes and made what they would say is a
loose science so it's like the science
of studying human behavior and that's
what the original and the issue was they
used a word that people also use for a
bunch of different they really should
have picked a different word if I'm
being honest but what the issue is is
guys and a lot of these guys are a bit
on the nerdy side like they're a bit
like and you know Tate describes them as
dorky and to be honest a lot of them are
because like for what
to be to be hating on them because I'm a
bit dorky you know but what kind of guys
are gonna study women for 20 years
you know it's not the guys it's screwing
a bunch you know anyways
so they come together to write in their
notes and some of these
who deal with a lot of women some of
these guys are married whatever now the
issue is there's influencers that come
in
you know like Tate and like other ones
and they'll use a lot of these guys
ideas and so Kevin Samuel's tape they
haven't really understood all the
concepts of red pill right so they
haven't gone into the deep and me too
right but the problem is we'll blow up
faster than them because we're better
communicators a lot of us so like Tate
comes in that man is eight like when I
look at the way he communicates it is
Art to me the way he tells stories like
I almost look at it as an art form like
it is beautiful the way he speaks this
is like a weird way to look at it but
and so basically the the influencers
will come in take what they've made and
then make art out of it and then a lot
of times the issue is the influencers
aren't accurate so they'll say things
that are a little bit off or whatever
and that the nerdy guys are like hey
I've been studying this for 20 years
I've done all this work you're using my
work for free can you please just make
sure you get it right give me credit or
whatever they they say because I think
Kevin Samuels they were mad at too
and the guys over here are like Hey
we're the ones actually doing something
you guys are just sitting in your
computers typing when we're the ones
creating movements we're the one making
change like all you guys do is study and
just like that's the way they see it I
don't think the red pill is actually
bitching but that's the way like a lot
of the influencers see it but the the
red pill is like hey you couldn't even
exist without me and the red pillars get
mad because the influencers will come in
and use their work when it's convenient
and say they're not a part of it when
it's not convenient does that make sense
they'll like distance themselves
whenever red pill starts to get a bad
name and this pisses the red pill guys
off because they're like well you
wouldn't even be here without our work
so it's this constant beef and I really
understand where both sides are coming
from because the red pillars
they just they're they're like the
credit police some of them they're like
credit credit and the the problem with
the red pillars is they can't make a
good enough product
because none of them are entertainers
Communicator because these are two
different art forms
the communicate the researchers
typically aren't as good as the
entertainers and the communicators and
what should happen is the two should
work together and they should advise
each other but the red pillars get mad
because they're like well why don't you
do the work why don't you do this this
and this and they're like well we have a
life we're not dorks
and I think both have valid valid
arguments she was two the the red pillar
is speaking to the average and so a lot
of times the red pillars when they give
it they don't even really give advice
but if they do give general advice when
they're asked it's for the average guy
it's not for a one percenter and the
influencers look at everything from one
percenter and they just say hey everyone
just be a one percenter but the red
pillars are a bit more realistic where
they're saying well not everybody can be
a one percenter you know what I mean so
it's just like a beat between the two of
them and
so when the red pillars say hey the
marriage contract is horrible and
honestly there's no way to deal with
women
um in the laws today and the influencers
are like you guys are just dorks who
can't like I can deal with women but the
red pillars are like Hey we're talking
about the average guy and so it's just
like a Miss communication because the
influencers will be like this is what
you should do and the red pillars are
like
well we could talk about should and how
the world should be but this is how the
world is and it really showed in Rolo's
vasectomy when in all honesty it's sad
because the the influencers won the
argument but the red pillars were right
like because their idea was the quickest
way to do it is to avoid having a thing
I think that's true like even my dad
when he first started his business he
waited to have kids like they gave the
first one up for adoption I'm not saying
it's the only way but we're gonna say
quickest right if you have 80 hours a
week you can spend 100 of it on work
that makes sense like logical and the
vasectomy thing like you're saying
that's the quickest way to get there and
the vasectomy is the only foolproof way
to do it and the red pillars are like
are the influencers are like well I
don't really have problems with women
like that you guys are dorks and I can't
I kind of see where they're both coming
from because
they kind of are dork some of them I
don't mean to be rude but I mean
compared to the tastes like the Tates
have like in every city or they used to
anyway they're living this crazy life
they're a ton of fun and the red pillars
are like they're doing these streams
about how you know
Michaela Peterson's a single mom you
know and they're just like in the red
pillars or and the influencers are like
dorm
and the red pillars are like you
wouldn't even be here without me do you
understand the beef
yeah that's that's the beef so I don't
mean any offense to anyone involved
because when I explain these things I'm
sorry I don't
I know someone's gonna get offended and
think it's about them all right guys
this is my first time having enough
money to gamble over like fifty dollars
so I'm starting today with 500 bucks I
expect to lose it okay I'm just
expecting this is an expense but we'll
see maybe I'm I'm a seasoned Gambler I
don't know I'll keep you guys posted we
can't actually film the gambling I guess
that's frowned upon but we're gonna give
you updates throughout all right you
could say I made it rain today I came in
with 500 I walked away with 800. the
problem is people keep going
I got up to like maybe 900 950 I started
going down again I was like nope nope
I'm Not Gonna Keep I'm gonna quit while
I'm ahead Make It Rain you know yeah I
will see where we're off to next
blessing was just Wilding blessing was
just he was wild and out there I really
respected it though because he would go
all in but it didn't work out too well
for him I won't lie did you did you keep
any money how much did you lose
it was at least 300
400. which is 500 bucks
no blessing we can't all be winners here
all right guys I told blessing not to go
back he went back now he lost another
what two 300 bucks a hundred so now what
are you out 400 I told him I told him
not to now he's blaming me because at
the end I told him to go all in but had
he tapped like I told him to tap
he would have made it so I don't know
what to tell you but I mean I and I will
take ownership I shouldn't have said go
all in I honestly just yeah that's my
bad my bad blessing I'm sorry you know
it's okay though it's okay we support
you here no don't go back don't go back
I think you need to cut take your owl I
received a message from Mr Cooper here
saying I love your content I'm a
bartender at Caesar's Palace Monique
Crisco cigar bar if you're in the area
I'll take care of your first round yeah
and now I'm here welcome welcome to my
Vlog hello welcome uh hello everybody
how did you know I was next door I did
not know you were next door I just saw
you were in Vegas I had no idea where
you were and I was like oh I'm working
today maybe she's around and I'll shoot
her a message to say if she wants to
come by and have a drink and I turn
around and she's here how long have you
been watching the contest
um I'd say about a year now are you yeah
yeah he's a day one he's a date fresh
and fit those those fresher fit shout
out to fresh and fit you can watch it
since it's fresh and fit wow wow yeah
Kevin Samuels you know rest in peace
That's My Boy Godfather The Godfather of
them all yes yes and now I'm with the
Godmother
yeah they should start calling Maya uh I
watch Jebediah is great yeah oh yeah so
yeah I'm Glad You Came yeah my I got my
girlfriend on to watching your content
as well yeah he's on board Paris shout
out to you Paris just pearly things
Paris we love you we love you here yeah
blessing did lose another hundred
dollars
he did
he says what happened he says what
happens in Vegas stays in Vegas but I'm
a snitch I'm a hundred percent
s-n-i-t-c-h snitch
he says he's gonna corrupt the file but
you know it's it's not gonna happen with
me
I'll get the file I'll get it it's going
in the Vlog Christian do not edit this
out
you cannot I can override you I'm a big
mean boss just ask O'Shea
I'm the worst
you were right